the head of high school suggested an
alternative which was that i should only
share
white conservative views on race so i
should i should only have
conservatives who um you know had white
skin
unbelievable since that would not
confuse or inflame the students
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
teacher and educator at grace church
school in new york city who recently
wrote a piece on barry weiss's sub stack
titled i refuse to stand by while my
students are indoctrinated
and then you can guess what happened
next cancel culture came to his door
paul rossi welcome to the reuben report
thank you dave it's a pleasure to be
here all right so
i've wanted to chat with you since i
read the piece
and we are going to link to the piece
below and i hope everyone will read it
but for people watching right now that
have no idea about any of this
can you sort of sum up the piece first
and then we'll kind of get into
everything that's happened since then
sure um basically uh for the last
i'd say four to five years there's been
an increasing uh change in the culture
of the school
as it started to implement what it calls
and
it's anti-racist programming
in the grades that i you know in the
high school that i
teach so grades 9 through 12 there and
you know i've noticed um like a series
of
very concerning things were happening
there
and uh basically a stifling of
expression
you know to the point where um
kids were afraid to be silent they were
expected to say things
say the right things uh if they if they
didn't say the right things they were
flagged
as problematic in emails um and a lot of
this was designed to sort of create a
certain culture
um a culture that's based on
critical race theory essentially so um
you know i started to hear complaints
from some of my own some
students in the school some of my own
students some who weren't my students
um that this you know this was becoming
extremely
uncomfortable and difficult and really
poisoning the atmosphere
in the school and i watched i witnessed
some things myself
in you know meetings that were
segregated by race
so we would frequently have whites only
meetings and you know
bipac meetings black indigenous people
of color meetings
and so as there was also a proliferation
of
of you know uh opt-in affinity groups
you know so uh basically
this this notion that you know
individual
opinions and ideas had to conform to
your sort of racial group and gender
group
and you know when things differed from
that uh
it was seen as you know anomalous or you
know not representative of what you
should think
and i had some you know some experiences
in classes that i teach i'm a math
teacher primarily but there
there's i also teach a persuasion class
where
some of the students in my in that class
complained of of having sort of a bubble
mentality and they
they weren't getting any of the other
types of opinions so i suggested to my
head of high school that you know maybe
we could talk about
uh we could bring in some of the ideas
of professor glenn lowery at brown
nick brown economist i'm sure you're
familiar with his ideas
because the students well a lot of our
discussion focused around the
protests and riots over the summer so
they wanted to maybe hear an alternative
opinion but i was told by my head of
high school
that it would be extremely problematic
and disruptive
if um to students
of color and and other students if i
shared a conservative views of a black
man
right to be clear he happens to be a
black conservative he's
yes he happens to be a black that was
not even in my initial
proposal it was simply that he has
certain views on race
in the racial issues that you know may
differ slightly from what grace
church school is pushing sort of a
center right but still you know very
mainstream you know if you look at the
opinions throughout the country
and the head of high school suggested an
alternative which was that i should only
share
white conservative views on race so i
should i should only have
conservatives who um you know had white
skin
since that would not confuse or inflame
the students
uh so this you know i didn't even
respond to that
email i wound up not even teaching that
unit at all
and i just i was so disgusted by
by that response which i just see as
self-evidently racist
the notion that ideas should be filtered
the dissemination of ideas should be
filtered based on the color of the skin
of the person who's speaking them
and i it's just completely
anti-intellectual and regressive in my
opinion
subsequent to that there was a self-care
meeting during the pandemic which was
ostensibly designed to
help students cope with the struggles
and problems with being at home stuck
you know maybe they're not able to come
to school
more than twice a week and you know in
this
in this meeting up came the white
supremacy slide
um saying that some of the
characteristics of white supremacy
culture included things like objectivity
and individualism and uh most
interestingly enough
a right to comfort so in the meeting
which is supposed to be
sorry the segregated whites only meeting
that was supposed to be teaching
students how to feel
you know more comfortable with this with
the events that were surrounding them
they were told that if they were white
they should you know question their
right to comfort which i found the
the height of irony uh so uh then
then the facilitator who was actually
very nice we got along
quite well i thought um raised the you
know
said asked the group of 200 students and
maybe 30 of my colleagues
you know whether they might be feeling a
white feeling
around these topics um and at that point
i
decided to question uh what that
actually meant
a white feeling what makes a feeling
white and
it was you know i was i was a little
miffed and concerned because i thought
that this was
blatantly racist but i was gonna try to
present my questions in a in a way that
was you know that wasn't antagonistic
and
later she did speak to me and tell me
that she didn't feel that
my questions were you know offered in
bad faith or anything so
what i was what i wanted to do by asking
the question was to open up the
discourse a little bit so that students
may
see me as an example and maybe model for
them that it's okay to question ideas
it's okay to have different viewpoints
and that's exactly what happened so
students in the chat window of the zoo
meeting started to ask
you know broader range of questions even
faculty joined in with some
questions of their own the facilitator
allowed it
there were a lot of questions against
capitalism so i put my own idea about
capitalism in there which was that
capitalism is extremely anti-racist
since it's done more
to lift people out of poverty lift
non-white people out of poverty than
than any other you know of its
competitors
um some of the questions that i put in
uh
also question the nature of racial
identification at all like why should i
identify as white why
why should i interject an identity based
on how other people see me why is that
necessary
and so that comment and some others made
their way out of the meeting sort of
violating the norm of confidentiality
to some folks that were not in the
whites only meeting and caused some
concern and agitation and then they had
to have meetings about the meetings and
then
it was sort of a week and a half of
upheaval
processing people felt harmed i was
brought into the
you know to speak to my head of school
and the assistant head of school
and i was you know asked you know how i
felt about what i had done
and i actually felt great so i said you
know i'm
i'm not contrite you know i i apparently
people are claiming that i've caused
harm but i
you know no one has come to me to
express this harm and and
you know they couldn't even explain the
causality of how my questions could
have caused the harm in the first place
and they kept
raising the stakes when they noticed
that i wasn't contrite and
they said well you know you you've
caused grievous harm
you've disturbed the student's peace of
mind
and at the end when i wasn't contrite
they said you know you it's raised to
the level of harassment at that point i
just ended the meeting
i had a subsequent meeting with the head
of the whole school
and uh you know he reiterated his
disappointment he
he had some pretextual reasons for being
upset but clearly
what was causing the problems in the
school
were the nature of my questions
not necessarily some of the pretextual
things that surrounded it sure
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about academia
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our academia playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics check out our
full episode playlist they're all right
over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell